Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of
FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker: But
the pile of feces in the live-action
Pinocchio is the most likable character.
Film Courage: What do you love
about Disney live action remakes?
Chris: I don't love anything about Disney live
action remakes. I think these are the worst films
of our time that represent everything wrong
with factory filmmaking and studio executives
and lawyers deciding they need to make a movie
to somehow preserve the intellectual property.
The Disney live action remakes with the
exception of a few, I would say the Jungle
Book by John Favreau, but almost all of
them have been incredibly unwatchable.
Thankfully the classic films on which they're
based still exist films like Pinocchio, Beauty and
the Beast, and whatnot but the live action remakes
have been the worst. Pinocchio in particular was
one that had me specifically angry because it was
first of all embarrassing at how bad the film was.
Everything wrong, you're taking the design of the
original Pinocchio and rendering it in computer
animation and it's the exact same design. You get
Tom Hanks to play Geppetto who it's interesting
in the original animation of Pinocchio it's
you have Geppetto and he's so excited to have
a young boy a son but when you take these
Concepts and from animation 2D animation
and put them into live action there's something
about it that is at the very least unsettling
of a live-action Tom Hanks dancing with joy that
he has a young boy, a young live boy that's his
I don't want to like I don't know how long
of a dramatic pause I could put there after
saying those words but there's something about
it that just seems weird in live action and I
think that that's something if you look at
animated shows like The Simpsons when they
talk about religion or politics or just so many
different issues that The Simpsons touch on you
could never do that in live action you couldn't
do a live-action sitcom that discussed those ideas
I mean you used to be able to with all in the
family but the only way to to tackle those ideas
unfortunately in a mainstream way is is in 2D
animation or at least you used to be able to
but the but the live-action Disney films are
just a travesty and sort of represent everything
wrong with modern movies today everything wrong
just the updating it for modern audiences with
unnecessary gender and race swaps that I
think that audiences are beginning to tire of
the live action doesn't really work there's
certain concepts and ideas that work best in
animation perhaps that's why perhaps that's why
the Jungle Book is probably the one that stands
out as it is the most watchable and probably the
best of them is because it's it's all animated
it's all animated with the exception of the young
boy but but my God these these Disney animated
or these Disney Animation translations to live
action are are travesty I feel like I could teach
a class where we just watch parts of Pinocchio
daily and I tell you why this isn't working
there's even a scene in which Pinocchio trips
over a pile of feces covered in flies and
part of me thinks that the reason that the feces
in Pinocchio with the the flies you could hear
the flies is so graphic it was like the animators
put that in to let us know yeah we know we know
too they are this bad and that film it just it's
horrific I really get the sense that it's it's
an attorney is saying look we need to remake
these and we need to brand them to remind people
it's it's somewhat similar to there was a trend
in the 90s to do sequels to classic Disney
animated films Cinderella to Lion King 2 Bambi
to and you can probably find them at yard sales
in the clamshell VHS casing you can find the
sequels to all the classic Disney animated
features and they're all completely forgettable
and I wish they never existed and I would say
the same for all of these Disney Live Action
films is literally an attorney saying well
just do it. It's disappointing to
see people like Robert Zemeckis
who made a short on a short list of
perfect films made Back to the Future
right and then to see Tom Hanks probably the
most beloved actor you could still call him a
star for them to team up with Disney to make it
is horrific and I just hope that Disney stops.
Film Courage: Not to get too graphic but I am
curious with the pile of feces and the flies,
in what context was that in the scene?
Chris: Well Pinocchio is skipping his way to
school. He's distracted and happens upon a pile
of feces. It's a completely unnecessary thing to
happen in the midst of the live-action remake of
the classic Pinocchio to put in this pile of feces
but I do believe that was a not so secret message
that the animators may have just decided to add
why would they do this otherwise there's there's
no point in it does it pay off later in the story
is it on his shoe and he says I don't recall that
it that it pays off or has meaning but the pile
of feces in the live-action Pinocchio is the most
likable character oh okay great I say that with a
straight face I have some numbers here Lion
King 1.6 billion dollars worldwide, Beauty
and the Beast 1.2 billion, Aladdin over a billion
worldwide, and The Jungle Book almost a billion.
So what about the fact that many
of these remakes are huge business.
Film Courage: You talk about a lawyer that
could be sitting behind their
computer figuring out numbers?
Chris: Yeah doesn't it make sense. Though
sure it makes financial sense to remake classic
and familiar intellectual property into another
form from live action or from animation to live
action. That makes total sense on paper. I think
these films are completely creatively bankrupt and
forgettable and it's unfortunate that audiences
would not be more discriminating when it comes
to these come to these movies so I just don't
think that we're going to be talking about
any of these live-action Disney remakes far
into the future. We will still be discussing
the classic films upon which they're based.
Film Courage: Now forgive me I'm not a
parent but I know that moms need a break,
dads need a break. Is this the kind of
movie that can say “Hey guys we're gonna
get in the car and go see a movie!
We are we going to see Pinocchio!”
Chris: There is definitely a school
of thought that I will say that the
reason that these movies are profitable
is they're effectively babysitters. So
that could also be a reason for the success and
also I kind of find it there's always a movie
and this is in particular around the holidays
usually Thanksgiving or Christmas and whatnot,
there's a movie that offends no one is not
interesting completely forgettable. But it's
the only movie the entire family can agree that
we can all go see together. That's why you see
movies opening on Christmas day right that it
is a thing a lot of movies open on Christmas Day
and not everybody wants to go see The Godfather 3
on Christmas Day but they'll go see something like
like a Disney live action remake. I despise these
films with every fiber of my being so I find they
I mean I guess the best thing you can say about
them is it keeps certain artists employed.